اراد الاوكرانيون ان يبدا جدول زياره
الوفد الافريقي للوساطه من اجل انهاء
الحرب على وقع دوي انفجرين على الاقل في
كييف وصل الوفد الذي يضم رؤساء ورؤساء
حكومات وقاده ست دول من افريقيا قلل الغرب
من فرص نجاح المبادره وصفا اياها بالاضعف
حكم مسبق مسيس بسبب موقفه من بريتوريا يضم
الوفد رئيس جنوب افريقيا سيرين الذي اختار
موقف الحياد والحوار منذ بدايه الحرب ورفض
ادانه نظام الرئيس بوتين عكس رغبه حلفاء
كييف تنص المبادره على انسحاب القوات
الروسيه ازاله الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
من بيلاروسيا وتعليق مذكره التوقيف
الصادره من المحكمه الجنائيه بحق الرئيس
بوتين بما يسمح بتوفير البيئه المناسبه
لوقف اطلاق النار
اسمع الرئيس فلودي ميرسي ضيوفه شروط كييف
قبل اي حوار مع موسكو
لن يكون هناك اي تفاوض مع روسيا وهي تستمر
في احتلال الاراضي الاوكرانيه لان ذلك
يعني استمرار الاحتلال وهدم تحاول روسيا
القيام به منذ سنوات وهي تحاول العوده الى
خدعها القديمه وخداع الجميع لكن روسيا لن
تستطيع خداع اي طرف خصوصا اوكرانيا ندعو
الى سلام حقيقي والى انسحاب الروسيين
حقيقي من اراضي اوكرانيا المستقله
يامل الوسطاء الافارقه الحصول على تنازلات
من الكرملين قبل قمه روسيه افريقيه مقرره
الشهر المقبل بعد كياف سيجري الوفد
مباحثات السبت مع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين في مدينه سانت بيترسبورغ قبل وصولهم
اكد الكريم ان الازمه الاوكرانيه يمكن
معالجتها بطرق مختلفه وان الرئيس بوتين
يدعم اي افكار لانهاء النزاع
لكل طرف في الصراع شروطه التي تزداد
وتتغير كل ما اشتد الاقتتال وطال وكثره
التدخلات الخارجيه المعلنه والمستتره طرحت
منذ بدايه النزاع عده مبادرات لوقفه
ولكنها توقفت كلها عند نقطه البدايه قدمت
الصين وثقه مكونه من 12 بندا من اجل تسويه
سياسيه للازمه لم يرحب حلفائك بالعرض نظرا
للتقارب بين موسكو وبيجي خطه السلام
الاندونيسيه التي اسهب في تفاصيلها وزير
الدفاع بروباو سوبيانتو خلال منتدى لم
تعجبه منذ يومها الاول مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
من جهته يحاول الفاتيكون ايجاد تسويه
للوصول الى السلام يتولى المهمه
خلال الشهر الجاري واجرى محادثات مع
الرئيس زلينسكي تعدد لم يقلص من زمن الحرب
ولا تداعياتها القاسيه على اكثر من قاره
وشعب لا يعرف اين تكمن العقده في اصحاب
المبادرات ام في المواقف الغربيه المسبقه
منهم ام في تشبث كل طرف مباشر في الحرب
بشروطه قبل اي تفاوض محتمل ولانها حروب
متعدده داخل حرب على الارض الاوكرانيه
دعوه السلام قد لا تسمع ولا تستجاب ليس
الان ولا غدا